These are the first six triangular number,
and they're formed by taking the position and summing all the numbers from 1 up to the position.
For the first number we have 1. For the second number we have 2.
Note that unlike Python we're indexing from 1.
N equals 3. The third number is formed by summing 1 + 2 + 3, which is 6.
The fourth number is 1 + 2 + 3 + 4, which is 10.
Now, how are we going to get these numbers--1 to 4--here to sum?
Well, Python has a nice way of doing that, and that's using range.
Now, we want the numbers to start at 1, and we want them to finish at 4.
Now, the way range works is I take the first input and starts there,
and it finishes at 1 less than the last input.
In order to get 4, we're going to have to take the range from 1 to 5.
When we come to write our procedure, we're going to use and instead of for.
That means that our range will have to be from 1 up to n + 1.
Now we're ready to write the procedure.
The procedure name is "triangular," and it takes an input, which is a positive integer n.
We want to output or return a number--the nth triangular number.
I'm just going to call it "number."
We want to loop through all the numbers 1 up to n in the range.
Don't forget the +1 there to make sure we go up to n.
We're just going to add each of the values i as we come to it in the loop.
Then when we're done we're going to return the number.